what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today i'm going to be
talking about
upper moon 3 akaza the best villain in
demonstration specifically about how
strong he actually
is i also just want to thank you guys
because our last demonstr video was
trending on all of youtube it was the
first time that ever happened on his
channel so that was an amazing
experience thank you for that
if you do enjoy seeing these demons
there videos on the channel and want to
keep them coming then the best thing you
can do is smash that like button to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and turn on all
notifications or you will miss upcoming
demonstrator videos and updates
if there are any specific topics you are
burning up to see let me know in the
comments
and while you wait for me to make that
video feel free to check out my growing
demons there playlist that includes
videos on all the breath styles
all demon moons all hashiras a bunch of
how strong is videos
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all so
if you watch
the new hype demonstrator movie moog and
train
you know that upper moon 3 akaza appears
out of nowhere
after they defeat lower moon 1 enma it
was absolutely brilliant because just as
we're lulled into a false sense of
security since usually you get to
celebrate after a hard
fought victory this sort of cool clown
looking dude
just strolls on into the movie it's our
first glimpse into what an upper moon is
capable of
and we skipped over upper moon six to
four and went straight to a top
three fighter and kyogre and goku the
undeniably strong flame pillar and one
of the demons their core's most powerful
fighters
had no chance of beating him not to
downplay the amazing things that ngoku
accomplished but in a fight to the death
and if the sun wasn't a factor
akasa was just way out of his league and
we didn't even see
akaza's limits during that fight but
they will become more clear as we move
on with the video
but to fully trace akasa's evolution and
strength let's rewind a bit
to before akasa was even a demon and
went by the name
hakuji this was over a century ago at
that point
hakuji was a poor kid who needed to get
stronger so he could get medicine for
his sick dad
even before he became a demon he was
considered a demon child
at only 11 years old he'd already
committed many crimes and had pickpocket
tattoo lines
put on his arm so that everyone would
know he was a criminal
and no matter how many times he was hit
tattooed threatened and so on he was
determined to keep stealing so he could
help out his dad
until his dad not wanting to trouble his
son anymore
took his own life hakuji started taking
out his frustration on the world and the
people in it
he fought with and beat seven adults
with his bare fists in one case
but then he ran into his future sensei
who clobbered him despite how badly
hakuji was beat
kaizo his soon-to-be sensei was
impressed that he only took an hour to
get back up
kaizo taught a bare fist fighting style
called soryu
and he helped train hakuji in it as well
we are going to gloss over hakuji's
amazing love story with keizo's daughter
which i cover in more detail in my best
villain and demonstrator video
so we can stick to the topic of strength
for this one what is important to know
is that hakuji was set to marry koyuki
kaizo's daughter he was
madly in love with her and she was madly
in love with him
despite the fact that he was a branded
criminal when he was 18 years old
he went to his dad's grave to tell him
of his upcoming marriage
only to come back and find out that
their well had been poisoned by a rival
dojo
the rival dojo resorted to such cowardly
means because they could never beat
keizo and hakuji in martial arts
not surprisingly after losing his sensei
and the love of his life he snapped
the incident was recorded in history
hakoji confronted the kenjutsu dojo and
killed 67 people with his bare fists
the maid who witnessed the scene lost
her mind
people thought the story was so absurd
and preposterous an 18 year old kid
beating up 67 swordsmen with his bare
hands
that they completely erased it from the
records after 30 years
but it was true hakuji managed that
before he even became a demon and got
the power
upgrade associated with that it was at
this point when hakuji
no longer had a reason to live that
muzon approached him he'd heard a
commotion
about a demon and want to investigate
only to find out that they were talking
about hakuji
a mere human at this point musan was
still thinking about creating the 12
demon moons they weren't an actual thing
yet
and so he gave hakuji a bunch of demon
blood to see if he could survive it
and become one of these demon moons
hakuji didn't care about anything
anymore
and let himself be turned into a demon
losing his memories in the process
but maintaining his will to become
stronger hakuji goes on to become upper
moon 3 akaza and it should be emphasized
that upper moons are a completely
different breed from lower moons
when the story begins it has been a
hundred years
since an upper moon has been killed
meaning they have much greater life
spans
than hashira's even upper moon 6 the
weakest upper moon
and akasa is not just any upper moon but
number three
so now let's fast forward to akkas fight
with rengoku by this point he's way
stronger than he was when he defeated 67
swordsmen he has demon enhanced strength
speed
and regeneration in addition to a blood
demon art known as
shock wave generation that we'll get
into in a bit during his fight with the
flame pillar
we learned that akaza can tell a
person's strength and how polished their
battle spirit is just by looking at them
he compliments rengoku saying he's close
to supreme territory
but he can't quite get there because
he's still human
rather than a demon as they fight akaza
reveals that he's killed multiple
pillars
up to this point although rengoku is his
first flame pillar
we see akasa's blood demon art at work
in this fight and
as rengoku remarks his shockwave attacks
reach him when he fires into the empty
air with his fists
and he moves at a fraction of a blank to
boot
so if a pillar tries to fight from a
distance it's pretty much
a lost cause they are forced to get
close and stay close
when akasa uses his destructive kill war
style attack as it's called in my
translation against rengoku's flame
tiger attack then goku is the one who
gets messed up while akaza's wounds heal
in the blink of an eye akasa is so
strong here that he's begging rengoku
his opponent
not to die because he wants to have more
fun fighting against
him and this is all the more significant
because although gyome is the strongest
pillar
at this point rengoku is no doubt in the
top tier of pillars strength-wise
so akaza is flexing on one of the best
akkas level is such that inosuke can't
move because he knows
he'd only be a hindrance if he tried to
jump in and help
when rengoku uses his strongest 9th
style purgatory attack
akasa counter attacks with destructive
kill obliteration
style and it gives rengoku a mortal
wound
that he won't be able to recover from
full props to rengoku who doesn't give
up even though he's fated to die soon
and tries to use akasa's trapped
arm in order to defeat him and thanks to
the sun that's coming up he almost
succeeds
but akaza's demon powers are way too
handy and he escapes by ripping off his
own arms and running away since they'll
regenerate soon enough anyways it's no
real harm to akaza
this fight was written so well that
ngoku arguably got the win
since akaza ran away before rengoku even
died
and asrangoku wished akaza didn't
succeed in hurting anyone else
still though in a pure one-on-one fight
it's clear that akaza was stronger
because all his injuries healed in the
blink of an eye and if the sun didn't
come up
he probably would have not only finished
off in goku but the others present
as well then goku was so strong that
when tengen
heard he lost he remarked so even when
goku lost to the upper moon demons
implying he was strong even compared to
other pillars and iguro the snake pillar
straight up said he doesn't believe it
and thus akkas is set up as a truly
formidable villain who without even
taking the fight too seriously remember
he was begging
and goku not to die managed to kill one
of the strongest pillars
so how can such an opponent possibly be
defeated
and what are the limits of his power
well we have to fast forward in the
story to when a much stronger
tanjiro and giu face off against him at
this point
giu says that it would not be an
overstatement to say that tundra's
ability is equal to a pillars
so this time you have at least two
pillar level slayers fighting against
one akaza and this is at the beginning
of the fight
they both get stronger as the fight goes
on during this fight akaza reveals that
he killed a water pillar 50 years ago
but giu isn't just
any water pillar and as i mentioned both
giu and tanjuro rapidly
improve over the course of this fight
giu mentions that this is the first time
in a long
while that he's up against a strong
opponent who overwhelms him and it
forces him to sharply hone his senses
markings appear on his face which is
kind of like going super saiyan for a
demon slayer
meaning a significant increase in speed
and power although akasa adjusted this
increased speed relatively quickly it is
during this fight that tundra realizes
the reason akasa can respond perfectly
to attacks even coming from his blind
side
is because just as tundra can sense
things with his sense of smell
akasa can sense fighting spirit and
killing intent so the key to catching
akaza off guard is actually to remove
all hostility from one's being as akaza
straight up punches
a marked hashida's sword and breaks it
possibly one of the greatest flexes in
all of anime
tundra is learning to better gain access
to the transparent or see-through world
which like markings is another huge
power boost
for the most skilled of demon slayers
access to this transparent world which
makes it seem like everything is in slow
motion
and his selfless state that erases
killing intent allow
tanjiro to actually cut akaza without
him seeing it coming
keep in mind at this point tundra is
above most pillars in power
and is clearly outclassing giu while
akasa launches an attack called final
form blue silver chaotic afterglow that
giu's dead com
is completely useless against tundra
manages to dodge the hundreds of blows
akasa launches simultaneously
well enough to remain standing then even
after tundra tells akaza he's going to
cut off his head akasa is unable to stop
the new tanjiro from doing it although
this may make akaza seem kind of weak by
comparison
we have to remember tanjiro at this
point has demon slayer markings the
strongest breath style
namely the dance of the fire god access
to the transparent world
an op selfless state that gives off no
fighting spirit or killing intent
and he's arguably the chosen one akasa
himself admits that tundra has reached
the domain of supremacy
aka the supreme territory that he was
seeking
all of his life and yet akaza is
not done his headless body continues to
fight on he
smashes an exhausted tundra into the
wall leaving him unconscious
despite not having a head the body
quickly regenerates from all of geu's
attacks
it seems like akas is about to evolve
into something else something that can
survive beheadings by nichiren blades
like muzon giu seems to be in a
hopeless situation since he's injured
and exhausted
while as he says demons don't feel
exhaustion or pain
and remember tundra is currently passed
out after hitting the wall
at this point despite tunjiro having
temporarily surpassed akiza's power
akasa could have finished them both off
however this is when the memories of his
past
life start rushing in and he hesitates
there is an internal struggle whether he
should evolve into a stronger demon
or finally let go and die as a human
tundra wakes up and goes to attack akaza
again but he's too
exhausted and drops his sword not even
being able to hold it properly
at this point it's an easy win for akaza
but rather than attacking them he
self-destructs and the memory and spirit
of his fiancee lets him fight off
muzon's influence and welcome his own
death
it's a great way to see this amazing
character go
rather than being definitively defeated
he chose that this will be his place to
die
he had the potential here to evolve and
surpass upper moon 2 but he chose to
forego
any more power for the sake of his
humanity and tranquility
all this time akkas didn't want to kill
weaklings as he always talked about he
wanted to kill himself
for being unable to protect his father
sensei
and fiance it's an amazing character arc
he's definitely my favorite villain in
this entire series
and now we all have a better sense of
how insanely strong
akasha was and could have been arguably
he remained
undefeated right up till the end where
he decided to take his own life
and i love the fact that his character
arc emphasizes that there are more
important things than just striving to
be the strongest at any cost
and that is it for my latest how strong
is video keep in mind
this is one of many so check out the
playlist to see
other ones and feel free to suggest any
characters
in the comments that i have yet to cover
if you did enjoy this video make sure to
smash that like button until it's blue
or whatever color youtube is making it
turn into these days
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and turn on all notifications or
you will miss upcoming demonstrator
videos and updates
if there are any specific topics you are
burning up to see
then goku style let me know in the
comments and while you wait for me to
make that video feel free to check out
my growing demon slayer playlist that
includes videos on all breath styles
all demon moons all hashiras a bunch of
how strong is videos and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself alpha
sigma
and red-haired raven and are the
one-tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrada pate heffa
al-jatal dr cortman the toasted chi rai
carlo
slick back emperor taku spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis baked buddhist and
cody hebert and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only gilgamesh angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki cricket xp very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami and water ted no ted sparky 65
joanne garcia fat boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saying
soul rise slice and dice and pill you
thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
animeopro link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
and if you do become a channel member
keep in mind you can find the link to
the discord by going to the community
tab and you'll see secret vip hidden
messages that only channel members can
see
and that's where you'll find the link to
the vip discord
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you